my name is Maegan ryoko's and i'm the
writer director and producer of the
feature film crushed crushed is a fully
independent feature film made here in
australia and when we set out to make
this film budget was really a massive
consideration when we were deciding on
our camera I have a really great DOP who
I've worked with several times before
Michael Steele so he came with some
ideas about what cameras we might be
able to use and what cameras we might
actually get access to for a really
cheap rate so he ends up securing us an
amazingly good deal for the Sony f55 and
originally the idea was that we were
going to have a three week shoot broken
up into two blocks six days before
Christmas and then two weeks after
Christmas and the idea was that we were
going to be a single camera shoot for
the majority of the time until the final
week and being a thriller film all of
the chase sequences and the climax we
were going to get a second camera for
that final week what we found out really
quickly though is that after that first
week of just having one camera we
realized that we were not going to get
the film we wanted in the can unless we
got a second camera so we had this
amazing deal to get the Sony f55 and we
went back to the camera house to see if
I had a second one we could use over
Christmas which is normally a really
quiet time of year but for some reason
everyone was shooting this particular
Christmas time and they didn't have any
more Sony f55 s available to be our
second camera but what they did offer us
was an Alexa which is a far superior
camera but we reshot for a week on the
Sounion 55 so we really thought about
okay can we make this second camera
being and Alexa actually work for us you
know obviously they have two incredibly
different looks and we did some tests
and consulted a few people who worked in
the online space grading and doing
coloring and we realized that if we were
to treat the elixir in a certain way we
would be able to match the two different
camera types in post because essentially
we were cross shooting with two
different cameras obviously not ideal
but when you're working on independent
film you just pretty much take what you
can get so we ended up working there's
the final two weeks of the shoot we did
have two cameras and two camera teams
which was a lifesaver and we really did
get the
the breadth of coverage that we needed
but obviously that really did present
some issues so some of the things that
we did to try and make sure that they
matched was we were using coral colored
filters anyway for this film we're
shooting in a drought outback kind of
farm area so we really wanted to have
that warm feel you know when we were
shooting it was roughly 3035 degrees
every day which i think is roughly about
95 Fahrenheit so really really hot and
we wanted to get that look on the camera
the other thing that we did is we shot
the elects are in log so that we had as
much information within the image that
well when we went back in post we were
able to then match the elixir back down
to the Sounion 55 the other thing that's
really interesting is that they're two
very different camera sizes and so a lot
of this film was shot during using
handheld and when you've got one camera
that's you know quite heavy compared to
the other lexer is a big bulky camera it
didn't mean that the two camera
operators the DOP you know and our first
or our second unit camera operator the
look of the handheld was different
because they were dealing with the
weight of different cameras and that you
know compounded by I think most most
camera people have got a particular
style when it comes to their own
handheld which is another thing to note
but having these two different sized
cameras and the bulk of the Alexa really
did come into play so in regards to the
style of the film we did research
Michael Steele and I came on board a
couple of months before we shot and we
did talk about style and some of the
stuff that we were looking at was stuck
with high contrast and shadows you know
this is a film about the grey areas of
what's right and what's wrong and and
secrets that are hidden and so we really
wanted to have this shadow play and some
of the stuff that we looked at we
actually looked at some stuff outside of
cinema so we're looking at things like
you know the the painter Caravaggio the
the darkness in some of those paintings
and also bill Henson photographer bill
Henson's so we looked at those and had
those as references for some of the
Nights stuff and in regards to kind of
camera moves and things like that you
know we were kind of looking at things
like the killing some of the beautiful
shots that they've got and the killing
are really great but we're doing a
low-budget film and the speed that we
had to shoot with meant that we couldn't
necessarily get beautiful dolly shots or
you know shot shots that that need quite
a lot of setup for a film like rushed so
we ended up deciding on the style that
we knew was going to assist us with
shooting a feature-length film in in
essentially three weeks while still
helping to tell the story and give it a
mood and a feel that was unique to
crushed and really enhance the plot and
the story so basically the way that we
decided to take the style of the film
was to begin with the film is is quite
steady we do use a little bit of
handheld but there are some sticks
there's also a few very basic dolly
shots early on and as the film
progresses the handheld comes more and
more into place so towards the end when
there's quite a long kind of climax
scene where there's chases and certain
people come into the situation and
certain people leave and you know we
wanted to have that kind of frantic
quality of the handheld while still
obviously getting a great image but
using that kinetic quality of handheld -
it kind of it in improve and help assist
that feeling of nervous energy the other
thing that we did decide to do which is
to do more with the lighting aspect of
the cameras that we use is again we had
a very small budget so we didn't have
any grips we only had a gaffer and a
best boy and so we really reduce the
number of lights that we needed for a
film like this so during the day the
majority of the film is shot with
natural lighting and at night we really
really used the bare minimum that we
could get away with there's a quite a
big chase sequence at the end in the
vineyard and we really couldn't afford
traditional filmmaking day makers so we
literally went to the local you know
road building construction light hire
place and got the the kinds of lights
that you would put up if you're doing
road work in the middle of the night and
and that presented a bit of a problem as
well for us well I guess I would say a
challenge and that is that the color
temperature of those lights are not
calibrated for films so it was something
that we just had to embrace and just
take into consideration when the lights
went up because we had no idea what
color temperature they were going to be
but I think overall we made the best use
that we could have for the budget that
we had I would have loved to have had
more lights to have lit the backgrounds
in some of the night sequences and also
to sculpt shadows and play which is some
of the stuff that we looked at really
early on but it just wasn't possible
with the speed and the facilities that
we were shooting under but I guess the
whole indie film kind of mantra is is
you know do the best with what you've
got and so Michael Steele definitely you
know pulled out all the stops and gave a
really really polished look - crushed
but also a look that we could achieve
really quickly and for a low budget in
the past I've used a lot of different
cameras in the past I've used the red
camera kind of prosumer version of the
Sony f55
the f3 on a previous film and we've also
shot on 16 millimeter and then obviously
on this film we use the the Sonia 55 and
the Alexa and we did also use black
magic for an octocopter shot that opens
the film at that point the octocopter
shot was done as a favor through a
friend and he was licensed for a certain
weight to go on the octocopter
and so black magic it was which you know
suited us fine anyway so I guess the
other thing to note is that when you
choose to use a number of different
cameras the post pathway can become a
little more complicated because you're
dealing with different codecs and
different people need you know certain
kinds of files so it does just make that
final kind of part of editing the film
I'm lining it a little bit more
complicated when you use so many
different cameras on the film set so
overall I'm really happy with the look
of crushed it's I think it's unique to
the film I think it's representative of
the the feel of the location that we've
got well at the same time giving us
something that we could kind of achieve
quickly and achieve for a really good
price so that's pretty much the look
that we came to for crushed if you'd
like to know more about crushed you can
head to our website crushed film calm
and we're also online at the moment on
itunes google play amazon x-box in
australia new zealand and north america
thank you